مرحبًا بكم في ميدواي يوتا، على بعد 30 دقيقة من
سولت ليك سيتي، نحن هنا
لمغامرة المشي بالأحذية الثلجية، وجهة لا
تختلف عن أي مكان آخر في العالم،
سينتهي بنا الأمر بارتداء ملابس السباحة
هناك في منزل كالديرا
المعروف أيضًا باسم يوتا  حفرة
لجلسة اليوغا على لوح التجديف من
الخارج تبدو وكأنها تلة كبيرة
مغطاة بالثلوج، يوجد مدخل
داخل هذا التل، لذلك تمشي هناك،
وهناك ممر يضربك البخار في
وجهك، وتشعر بما يحدث في هذا  في
منتصف فصل الشتاء، هذه المساحة الدافئة
داخل التل، توازن جيد،
تجربة اليوجا على لوح التجديف، في أي مكان
آخر يمكنك القيام بذلك في الينابيع الساخنة في
كهف، هناك ثقب كبير في السقف
يسمح بدخول الضوء الطبيعي
للبالون الكاريبي للمياه، إنه مكان مثالي لقلبك
كلبك في الماء
هنا في Utah Creator، فنحن نرحب بك
للاستمتاع بالمياه المعدنية الغنية التي يتم تسخينها بالطاقة الحرارية الأرضية بدرجة 95 درجة
والسماح للناس
بالاستحمام والطفو والاسترخاء فقط،
لدينا أيضًا معدات الغطس
وتجربة الغوص تحت الماء، يمكنهم أخذ
فصل دراسي والعودة إلى المنزل  معتمد بالكامل،
العمق الفعلي هو 65 قدمًا،
لذا يمكنك الخروج لمدة أسبوع والذهاب
للتزلج وفي المساء، يكون الغوص
فريدًا ومختلفًا تمامًا